it really is a pleasure to be here at
Stanford it's a partnership that Xerox
has felt very positive about over the
years and particularly I have to say
between the University and our Palo Alto
Research Center which is just a few
miles away where I was this morning and
some certainly very distinguished
graduates from the bee school Barry Rand
being one of them who rose to be a top
executive at Xerox as well so for a lot
of reasons it's great to be here with
you today and I have about 45 minutes
not even and what I really like to do or
four things and what I've been asked to
do is four things to talk about the past
and not just to tell the story but most
importantly to talk about the lessons
learned along the way and there were
many to share a few thoughts on
leadership and particularly leadership
at a time of crisis and then describe
what I do what's a typical day and talk
a little bit about just the you know
priorities and how I spend my time and
most importantly leave plenty of time to
take your questions so so I'll get to it
and as Bob mentioned in 1998 and early
1999 Xerox seemed to be doing very very
well
market shares were improving our stock
had risen and quite frankly was
outpacing the market by a wide margin at
that point in time we had made a change
in leadership brought in a CEO it
appeared to be doing very well and so
most of us were kind of had our set
sight on a fairly bright future I was
actually running an independent startup
company that Xerox had focused on to
really develop the soho market and
desktop products at the time so i think
it's fair to say that with alarming
speed things began to unravel in late 99
and 2000 and they unravel with alarming
speed but the problems generally take
place over decades so important to note
but we had also taken on a massive
reorganization it did not go well
competition was stiffening big time and
we were focused on inward kinds of
issues and then at that point in time
economy started to weaken around the
world as well
that was when we actually discovered
accounting improprieties in Mexico and
that actually spread into a worldwide
SEC investigation one of the first of
this decade I often say we were early
adopters of the corporate crisis and I'd
have to say that we took some actions
that in the broad daylight of hindsight
were just strictly dumb at the time so
we actually captured it and called it
the perfect storm what else could go
wrong and I think it would be fair to
say that this is a company that could
have managed through a few of these
issues but the cumulative impact really
overwhelmed the company and set it back
on its heels so by May of 2000 we were
in deep trouble revenue and profits were
declining our cash on hand was shrinking
as Bob mentioned 19 billion dollars of
debt 150 million dollars of cash I could
not find the hundred and fifty million
dollars of cash it was scattered around
the globe and so customers were not
happy we had employees who were
defecting who certainly didn't want to
to be a part of a company that was
heading south our shareholders had seen
the value of their stock cut in half and
continued to head south and then there
was this little matter of an SEC
investigation that would had spread
around the world this was about the day
I was named president and chief
operating officer and typically in a
talk like this where you'd say it
fulfilled a lifelong dream and that was
not the case this clearly was a case of
a responsibility that I have to say I
accepted with equal parts of Pride and
dread but I very quickly figured out I
had two really important aces in the
hole the first was a customer base that
actually treasured the Xerox brand
wanted Xerox to survive so people who
were willing to work with us during this
difficult period of time and the second
was an incredibly talented and committed
workforce who would do just about
anything to save the company and so we
really did roll up our sleeves and begin
the hard work of addressing all these
issues and I'd have to say in the
beginning most of that time was spent
listening to employees to customer
and industry experts and customers told
us we had great technology but our
responsiveness had slipped incredibly
all right industry experts told us that
we had a lot of great technology but we
better make some clear choices and focus
as it related to our market
opportunities and employees told us that
they would do whatever it took to save
the company but we better provide clear
direction and do it quickly so we laid
out a pretty bold plan didn't really
qualify as taking a rocket scientist in
terms of what had to be done the first
piece was to fix the liquidity issues
very very quickly and raise cash both
through you know some asset sales as
well as incredible management of all
cash sources we had to restructure the
cost base it was very clear to me we had
a huge cost base problem so we set a
goal of taking a billion dollars out
knowing that it wasn't sufficient but
that we would strive to take the billion
dollars out as quickly as possible just
to begin this process of competitiveness
and the third leg was one that was
really important to the Xerox team and
that was is that we would actually
strengthen our core business actually
invest in our core business at the same
time as we were restructuring the
company and fixing the liquidity issues
so the results really have been fairly
stunning based upon the challenges that
we had on the liquidity front you know
we really raised about two and a half
billion dollars of cash quickly but we
took a lot of tough actions we
outsourced to our office manufacturing
it was a union shop we exited our small
office/home office business a business
that I started and we focused on
operational cash generation with a level
of discipline and focus that was just
extraordinary and on the cost front we
took out the first billion then we
started on the second billion we're
actually taking on our third billion now
we reduced our selling and general and
administrative expenses by over 25% we
cut our capital spending in half and the
most painful thing we reduced our
worldwide employment by about a third
and when you have an experience like
that you really stay focused on making
sure that you have a business model
that's sustainable and can really
support the cost and the infrastructure
going forward
so but as much as I think we did some
dramatic things reducing our debt our
debts been cut in half and what's left
is just kind of the customer receivables
we improved our cash position we've had
great cash generation about a billion
and a half per year we have three and a
half billion dollars of cash on hand as
a matter of fact during the SEC
investigation we had basically lost our
financial staff and we had no CFO in the
company so I was acting CFO and had to
manage through the SEC investigation but
when I finally hired a CFO after we had
resolved the investigation and I said
you know I've been acting as CFO and you
know I'm I really don't have a
sophisticated financial background here
and I'm really anxious to hear you know
what your thoughts are on our cash
strategy and he looked at me and he said
hoarding would be the strategy for cash
and it was quite appropriate so as proud
as I am of the financial turnaround it
is the progress on the third leg of the
strategy we didn't take a dollar out of
research and development we have both we
have for research facilities around the
world we spend about a billion dollars
on research and development and as a
result the past couple of years have
been our biggest product launch years in
history and I'm really on firm footing
when I tell you we have just an
incredible portfolio of innovative
offerings and solutions for our
customers that are combinations of
extraordinary hardware software and also
our people so it's good to be looking at
a set of positive results everywhere we
look
fortunately the trends are going in the
right directions our margins are where
we want them just this year alone we
took three billion dollars off of our
balance sheet and our equipment sales
which is really the driver of our
company going forward have been growing
for the last seven quarters and most
importantly we're winning in the
marketplace customers are voting with
their checkbooks so this is just to give
you a perspective on where we've been
I think it would be fair to say that a
few years ago people were writing our
obituary and now we're getting some some
very nice quotes like like really
looking at a great turnaround so this
has been really I think the opportunity
of a lifetime and certainly a thrill and
I think the the biggest understatement
would be to say that I've learned a lot
along the way and that's what I'd like
to turn to now and as we reflected on it
there really 10 areas that are basic
certainly nothing terribly brilliant but
they seem to get lost in the shuffle
when you are going through an experience
like we have the first is I kind of
characterize it as look before you leap
as Bob said I'm a life for 28 years at
Xerox I really know the place and I have
to say that when you've grown up in a
company you think you know all the
answers and if you couple that with some
fairly intense decision-making which I'm
noted for it can be a pretty dangerous
combination so fortunately I was slowed
down and spent probably the first 90
days on planes just listening to
employees and customers and just anyone
who had a view on what the problems were
just to make sure that we would be
addressing the core problems and not
just addressing the symptoms of the
problem and it turned out to be quite a
different list than the list that I had
originally anticipated and I have to say
that we were in a position where
everybody was kind of putting out fires
but not fixing the fuel leak that was
causing the fire so it was really an
important part of the exercise taking
the precious time that was required to
really understand what the issues were
in the company and I'd have to say if we
didn't go through that I think I'd be
giving a very different talk today the
second is really about communication and
it's always important but in a time of
crisis it is absolutely the single
biggest priority that you have
and actually that's when people tend to
go underground when things are ugliest
and this was a really important part of
the turnaround strategy I have to say
that I I worried a lot and I had a lot
of doubts but when I communicated with
all of our constituents constituencies I
was pretty transparent about the size of
the issues I used to call it the brutal
truth and give people a sense of really
what was happening in the company but
also confident about a plan that would
overcome those issues and the
combination of hopefully giving people a
sense that we really do know what's
happening here and it's not good and we
have developed a plan that will address
those issues was really the the approach
that we used and I think our employees
really appreciated that and my message
was always pretty consistent you know
here's the problem and here's the
strategy and here's what you can do to
help and to this day if you ask Xerox
people about the turnaround at Xerox
they will tell you what they did to turn
around the company because there was
just an incredible alignment of people
around saving every dollar taking care
of customers really trying to make sure
that the company focused on the
priorities and we asked them to make a
choice roll up their sleeves and go to
work or quite frankly leave Xerox and
and I think that was just a hugely
important exercise for everybody to make
that conscious decision so fortunately
the response was really quite positive
and we really started to retain all of
our people and started to make a lot of
progress as it related to the turnaround
so when people ask me how we
accomplished so much so quickly I always
am quite clear and saying that you have
to have a good strategy it can be
roughly right though and a good plan is
important but it is in big companies it
is the alignment of your people around a
common set of objectives that is the
single advantage to being big to have
alignment and scale and use
constructively to really accomplish your
goals otherwise quite frankly than it is
a disadvantage the third lesson that I
learned was about crisis being a
powerful motivator it enables you to do
things that obviously you should have
been doing all along and I think that in
this case I probably wouldn't have set a
goal of taking out a billion dollars
immediately had we not had this window
of opportunity called a crisis and
certainly in the past a lot of those
kinds of efforts would have been met
with a lot of resistance but given the
crisis no one could argue it was either
a billion dollars or it was the gallows
for Xerox so that was really hugely
important in terms of taking advantage
moving quickly getting things done
quickly while you had this kind of
powerful motivator across the company
since then not to lose the intensity of
this focus on competitiveness and being
best-in-class we've been deploying Lean
Six Sigma in the company which is a way
to kind of create systemic productivity
improvement throughout the company and
it's it's a marriage of the speed and
simplicity of lean tools with the the
rigor and the discipline of the Six
Sigma tools so this has given us a
process and a language and a toolbox to
address really tough problems problems
that have been around this company for
decades and I have to tell you it's been
a great partnering tool we we partner
with a lot of our customers providing
them with black belts and resources to
solve their productivity issues and it's
created an enormous value for us as a
company this year Lean Six Sigma will
bring a hundred and sixty million
dollars of profit to the bottom line in
Xerox so and we'll double that next year
so we are we have an army of trained
resources throughout our company I'm a
green belt and I have to say that it's
been an enormous help in maintaining the
intensity of constantly staying ahead of
the productivity curve but I think the
point is is that we're we've taken out a
lot of that cost without harming the
core business and in many ways it's made
us more efficient it's increased our
clock speed
it's removed a lot of the bureaucracy
and and that's why it's hugely important
to kind of maintain that focus on
productivity and competitiveness for
companies like Xerox fourth is I kind of
call it back to basics and you're very
often intrigued by and and it's tempting
to think about quick fixes and new ideas
you get a lot of help - there's a lot of
people who have great ideas that
certainly want to help but in our
experience a lot of the answers really
were about getting back to basics simple
things Xerox had a incredible heritage
and quality one that we had lost putting
discipline back in all of our processes
aligning our people around objectives
lots of tough and regular operations
reviews and a lot of strict management
of the usual things like you know
inventory and gross margins and capital
and it's amazing how quickly that
discipline can unravel in a company and
it's not trivial to build it back so
processes that had taken years to
develop kind of lost their way overnight
and but the good news is is that they
they can be built back and they are
clearly the only way you can run a
business to deliver predictable results
this is an interesting one because I
kind of call it following your instincts
and we are an incredibly data-driven and
process driven company but after you get
the data and after you listen and you're
open-minded instincts based upon good
management experience play a big role in
moving quickly and making decisions we
had actually had a ton of consultants in
to Xerox over the 90s who helped us kind
of organize along many lines we had we
were organized by industry we were
organized by product we were organized
by segments we were organized by
geography and as I was making my initial
travels around the world I was looking
for anybody who felt any degree of
accountability for anything and man it
was just me it was scary and
so despite what looked good on paper we
unraveled it and it's not perfect but
it's clear and I can look people in the
eyes and I know what they're accountable
for and you can hold them accountable
for it and it was a huge enabler for us
to make operational progress the six is
about corporate culture and it's kind of
gotten a bad rap lately as a matter of
fact when I was making my initial rounds
I was visiting a big customer and a new
CEO for a bank and he was coming in with
kind of a turn around Charter and wanted
to give me a lot of advice about what
needed to be done at Xerox and we owed
him a lot of money so I was listening so
in any case he said you got to kill the
culture it's the the culture in this
company that has made it you know
sluggish and bureaucratic and you've
lost your edge and your competency and I
was listening but I have to tell you I
realized it was kind of nonsense what is
a culture other than a collection of
people and behaviors that you have
within a company and it's a great way of
pointing out you know it's your problem
to the people of a company and cultures
clearly needed to be adapted ours needed
to gain a lot of speed we needed to do
away with some things but you have to
bring the culture with you if you want
to get things done in a big company and
it was hugely important that we really
built on the strengths of the Xerox
culture to enable us to do what we had
to do and our culture puts a premium on
things like quality and empowerment
results diversity fairness customer
corporate responsibility things that are
really people are proud of and quite
frankly it's the reason a lot of people
came to Xerox and why a lot of us stayed
so if it helped us achieve greatness in
the past in the past hopefully it can be
a path for the future as well vii has to
do with focusing on on customers never
forgetting there's reason custom that
that companies exist but when bankers
are calling and shareholders are
knocking on the door it's really
sometimes easy to lose sight and forget
the most important constituency of all
and that's the customer but I have to
say that we decided as a team that that
would be our number one
executive focus that we would own
customer relationship so we all took key
clients and went out and really
personally communicated to our key
clients solved problems addressed issues
we've kept that program away so we call
our focused exec program but it's hugely
important and it's built into the fabric
of our company but just to ensure that
every single person I'm talking the
chief accountant you name it has
responsibility for a set of customers
that they visit with and not only is it
great for the customer to get the kind
of you know senior attention that's
required but it's great for our
executive team because it provides them
with that grounding principle of what
our customers are thinking and it's
really been hugely helpful
viii is something I call the vision
thing and I guess the the best parallel
is is that even when Rome was burning
people wanted to know what the city of
the future would look like and I have to
plead guilty that I didn't immediately
get that part I would do lots of town
meetings and I was always amazed that
the most frequently asked question is
what Xerox would look like when we came
through the turnaround saying there why
aren't they asking me are we gonna make
it are we gonna survive yet they were
beyond that they were kind of if we're
gonna roll up our sleeves and we're
gonna be dedicated we have a passion
about this I want to make sure that I'm
working for a company that'll be a great
company and not just a company that
survived it was a very good sign and
certainly a great example of the
resilience and optimism of Xerox people
but I'm not very patient I have to say
with the vision thing and vision
statements and all that so we decided to
do something a little different and
probably our biggest critic at the time
and wear a lot of the ugliest headlines
were present was in The Wall Street
Journal every day you'd pick it up and
there was some horrible story about
Xerox and so we decided to write a
fictitious Wall Street Journal article
dated in 2005 that would really describe
where's your ox would be in 2005 with
all of the elements if you will of
strategy and metrics and goals and and
opinions and feedback we we had quotes
from you know analysts and from our
toughest critics and
and we basically it forced us to kind of
express express our vision and our
strategy and in plain English and you
know we talked about everything from you
know what technology we'd be bringing to
market to what the revenue growth would
look like and and how we'd like to be
seen and it was incredibly useful people
really rallied around this vision and to
this day no matter where I go in Xerox
that article comes out and I'd say
fascinatingly 80% of it probably is
pretty accurate and I get asked about
the other 20% all the time and you know
well when's this gonna happen and I said
like hello we made it up and it's that's
how people felt about it at the time it
was just an extraordinary thing so
ix is about good critics I like to think
about myself as being open and
approachable but I have to say that this
is an area where when you rise in the
ranks so all of a sudden people around
you want to please they're a little bit
more respectful a little bit more
intimidated and you have got to make
sure that you have sources of honesty
and critique available to you it's
something that you have to work at you
can't leave it to chance
it's just hugely important what it
allows you to do and it's such a gift is
to actually ensure that you're able to
deal with problems early and when they
you know fester in the environment
they're bigger and bigger and eventually
clearly they become crises so it's it's
truly a gift last thing and we'll talk
then a little bit about leadership but
it's about sense of humor and
perspective and you know not to forget
that part of what you makes work so
great is is that you enjoy what you do
you enjoy the people that you work with
you'll laugh a lot and you have this
kind of relationship and community that
becomes awfully important to a
satisfying work experience and taking
yourselves too seriously even with the
dire problems that we
would have been a big problem we had to
laugh at a lot of mistakes we made a lot
of mistakes we laughed at ourselves but
I don't believe any of us would have
survived the past four years if we
didn't truly look forward to coming to
work every day and huge goal for
everybody so when I talk about
leadership I I'd like to just say I
think everybody has read so much about
leadership and certainly I had been in
lots and lots of roles where I led teams
and you learn about it you read about it
but until you come face-to-face with the
impact of leadership I have to say I
don't think you can fully appreciate it
and with that I would tell you that poor
leadership can do damage overnight
it's amazing the extraordinary damage
that poor leadership can do and really
good leadership can move mountains over
a longer period of time it's got to be
consistent and certainly takes a lot
longer time to make progress I actually
read a book from one of your alma mater
z-- who actually had a big impact on me
and it was during a really important
time and it was it was good to great and
it was about companies that had
extraordinary results over a long period
of time and of course then a research
project to analyze what with a common
set of attributes for these really great
superior companies and and only a few
companies really met those standards but
the not so surprising answer of course
was the quality of the the leadership
and but here's what was surprising that
these leaders were almost unknown
they weren't the household names and
that they were this kind of paradoxical
blend of personal humility but an
incredibly strong professional will and
they really focus on building teams
giving credit to others doing whatever
it takes to make their company great but
it is about their companies and it's not
about themselves and it's just sounds
very logical that if you focus on the
institution your contributions are far
more likely to be lasting ones but but
one that may have eluded us particular
during the period of the 90s so last but
not least was how do I spend a day and
I'm glad to say that there is no such
thing as a typical day and whether it's
a crisis or an opportunity or
circumstances change or you know stuff
happens it's really certainly not
typical so I thought I would actually
just tell you what I do what I'm going
to do and I have done this week because
it should be pretty typical but I
actually started in my office on Monday
morning we have a board meeting next
week it was my last time in the office
so it's so a little bit of time just for
preparation there then I actually flew
to Washington to meet with a very large
customer and then I spoke to the senior
management meeting of another very large
customer actually Fannie Mae and in
Washington as you know they're going
through their own version of a corporate
crisis so so they had an audience that
was really interested in in in hearing
what the Xerox experience was and then I
flew out here to San Jose all day
yesterday we met with our Fuji Xerox
colleagues we have a equity partnership
with Fuji Xerox it's how we distribute
in asia-pacific we also have a
technology and development exchange with
Fuji Xerox so we met with our senior
team there and had dinner with them last
night this morning I met with our
employees at our Palo Alto Research
Center and then a customer meeting and
then my visit here this afternoon
tomorrow we have 3m in for a day for an
executive exchange on the topic of
innovation we're hosting it at Parc but
it should be a great half-day and then I
fly to Clearwater Florida where I'm
meeting with the CEO of tech data or
largest indirect distributor and I'll
actually speak with their senior
management team and then finally
tomorrow night return to or Friday night
return to Stanford so the good news is
is that it's a week out of Stanford so I
travel most of the time because that's
where the work gets done that's where
our customers are and that's where Xerox
people are which is really the the core
of what I do is meet with customers and
Xerox people the most important
constituencies so so that's probably
pretty typical so
my last message is by the way that if
you believe in communications being as
important as I do I my title should
probably be chief communications officer
cuz that's a lot of what my job is about
now and if you listen as much as you
talk it's time well spent because it
keeps you grounded and connected to the
marketplace to your customers to your
people and gives you just an invaluable
source and rich set of information so in
any case hopefully I've given you some
food for thought and I would be
delighted to open it up and take your
questions so the question was about
characteristics and of work ethic and
what served me well perhaps in attaining
a CEO position I guess I begin with I'm
a pretty intense worker in the sense
that I I I don't like any idle time so
I'm generally try to get a lot
accomplished in a short period of time I
actually think that came from or
hopefully a skill I developed being a
working mother I think having children
while I was working always put
boundaries on my work life so that I
wasn't this day at the office
for 14 hours a day that wasn't my stick
I wanted to get home when I was home and
have dinner with my husband and my kids
so the ability to accomplish a lot in a
short period of time became for me the
most important work ethic and it's kind
of stuck with me I'm a early riser I go
to the gym every day because I it's for
my head just to kind of start the day
with with a fresh perspective and I stop
working if I'm in Stanford at 6 o'clock
I don't stay rarely any longer I had
lots of dinners now on lots of other but
but I do have this belief that
you need space from work to have
perspective and and you have to make
that space available for you work will
consume as much as you will give and
that's clearly the case and and I should
also reflect back in the 2000 2001 I
worked seven days a week 24 hours a day
just because that's where the company
was and there just wasn't any space but
that's not the characteristic of my
career and now I think that in a place
where you know there's a little bit more
balance but you have to make it no one
gives it to you and I've always been
pretty tough on creating boundaries
about my workday and it's really been
helpful I think both in the sense that
you seemed to get more accomplished when
you have those boundaries and it also I
think is a much more rewarding life as
well you don't see a need for an
immediate
you know I started out in sales at Xerox
and which clearly at that point in time
to to require an MBA and it just never
you know then I had kids so the
trade-offs and time became really
difficult to make those kinds of
sacrifices and you know when I weighed
the commitment against my own ambition
I'm not sure my ambition measured up to
to get you know really just the
additional training that clearly would
have been helpful but I would tell you
this I have had to make up for not just
not having an MBA but also not having a
lot of the training and a company that I
run by an incredible amount of intense
learning on the job so you know I was
acting CFO during renovated restatements
in American business and I learned from
every resource I could find as it
related to financial training so I
probably got there in a very
non-traditional way in terms of learning
and it probably would have been nice to
have had that head start in the
background and the experience through an
MBA but you know it just wasn't in the
cards when I was
in my work career and I never made the
trade-off from from that point on so it
probably was just not something I
planned for yes CEOs who are men who
credit their wives with not only getting
them to where they're in their career
but giving them a full home and family
life I'm wondering what role your
husband played and if he was balancing a
career of his own and how you manage
that he works for 35 years he's retired
now okay for three years so the great
news is is that I'm not sure I could
have pulled this job off without having
you know full time support at that point
and my kids are older now too so it's a
little bit of a different situation but
I'd say we the last 25 - the first 25
years were constant trade offs with
regard to you know certainly both of our
our jobs and careers I think we've made
some decisions that were really
important for us that we both both
wanted careers neither one was willing
to kind of say I come first we've fought
that battle for years and as a result
made this agreement that we weren't
going to relocate for the benefit of the
owners job that tough turn it down
that's not the stick that we were on
that we really needed to have kind of a
feeling of importance with regard to
what we did and
and that we would turn down some other
opportunities so that we didn't have to
kind of displace the other person and we
also decided that we also actually had
this great goal to be good parents to
that was certainly not the easiest of
things during those years so um you know
this thing is always about choices and I
think you get into trouble when you
don't make clear choices well we made
clear choices and that was work and kids
that's it so when I first became CEO and
they were putting together kind of my my
personal history and they were picking
up all this stuff from my resumes I had
to stop them because I knew it would be
published I said
boring but the fact is is that you know
we raised a family and we worked and for
a long time that's really all there was
room for so I think we made it work
because we made an equal kind of
sacrifice in terms of you know our free
time and what we spent it on and there
was for us and it's not fair buddy there
was no particular resentment about kind
of this you know I come first scenario
just wouldn't work for us how you
addressed the employee morale issues
when you're laying off there the
workforce yeah it was huge I think it
was the toughest toughest thing we did I
should say that we did everything we
could to save jobs even if they weren't
Xerox jobs so when we negotiated an
outsourcing arrangement for
manufacturing we forced the transfer of
at least a third of the manufacturing
employees with the outsource contract so
that we can save as many jobs as
possible we have forced our back-office
operations to GE capital they took all
our people so right there you know we
had you know several thousand employees
who were working not for Xerox anymore
but we did a lot through managing
attrition and retirement and trying to
manage down the rank says but at the end
of the day obviously we shut down
businesses we made a lot of tough
decisions so probably the best example
is that I shut down the small
office/home office business that I
started a thousand people and you know
there's only one way that you can do it
and at least give people a sense of that
you care and that to do it face
and so that was our rule that we always
did it in person and met with the
organization so that it was never
delivered indirectly you know we had we
had a context for it which was a
corporate crisis so it wasn't like this
was you know justify desire it was by
necessity so I do think that you know
the context of you know having a
bankruptcy rumors in the papers every
day built a little bit of more
sensitivity from the employee population
about the decisions that we were making
you know it was it was a survival kind
of thing so all I can say is is that you
know you certainly have to build an
honest and credible story about what
you're trying to accomplish and what
you're trying to do you got it deliver
bad news face to face and taking tough
questions and to own up to the decisions
that you're making and then you got to
work really really hard to convince
people that you're trying to put
together a company that isn't going to
go through this roll over and over again
and that's really what we've been about
is it's really the kind of adaptability
and sustainability that a company needs
so that you don't go through that kind
of time you know retching disruption
that you - structuring this cause it's
one of the main reasons why I'm so
passionate about Lean Six Sigma because
it's a it's a problem curious discipline
that forces you to deal with issues with
and you know and that's why I want our
people so amazing it so that they help
solve them they fix them we don't let
this problem develop into something that
has to be done again so I think people
know that we suffered through this and
that we've tried hard to I think make as
many decisions as possible about saving
jobs but at the end of the day and I
used to have this conversation with our
union it's no jobs for Less jobs it was
just absolutely essential what was going
on so no easy answer and I still think
the organization bear scars I feel
blessed with people that are loyal and
terrific and love the company but it
definitely scars company and it's a no
way to run a company that's for sure in
the back leadership team you assembled
and to put together usually the crisis
in if he could be focused on where they
kept the team intact as you went through
the process a wheel
but when I came into the job that I knew
that there would be certainly some
people that probably weren't thrilled
with the decision that I'd become CEO of
Xerox so the first thing I did was sit
down it was a 12 member team and I sat
down with everybody and kind of did the
same thing I did with employees which is
you know no time to waste I can't be
looking over my shoulder you know if you
sign up you know you have to be signed
up totally otherwise I'll make it really
attractive for you to leave because I
can't waste any time with people who
don't buy in and care about you know the
corporation the same way the same way I
do 3 out of 12 left and I did it very
attractive for them to leave so that you
know they clearly wasn't you know they
can own up to the fact that they really
didn't want to stay and that was a good
thing because it happened quickly and if
there's one thing I learned throughout
my career that you know the quicker you
deal with those things the better off
you are so I brought in some new people
and made a lot of changes also within
the team but wound up then with 12
person team that's still with me today
some of them in different roles but
they've all stayed I think the part that
people don't appreciate it was obviously
a very difficult time at Xerox very
tough decisions not a lot of rewards and
recognition either
you couldn't really buy your way through
this one because there was no money but
the feeling of accomplishment when you
can contribute something that really has
an impact is enormous and this team
feels this extraordinary sense of
participating in the last three or four
years and having this huge impact of
putting a company back on its feet and
bringing back you know quite a brand
icon to profitability and stability so I
think the satisfaction of what's been
accomplished has been a huge retention
vehicle for this senior team and and
we're like a family you know it really
does create an environment where in that
general run when you saw that with anime
we we wanted to make it like we're gonna
fail or if you went through that
situation have you shared that or you
did we do well there are a lot of points
in time I you know certainly knew what
the odds were on these kinds of things
and certainly our odds were not good at
succeeding and I often think one of the
things that was happened to be a good
thing at the time is is that not having
been trained if you
to be a CEO there were a lot of things
that I took on that probably you know I
didn't have the if you will the
perspective of someone who had the
experience and gone through it and I
think it kept me perhaps a little bit
more in the dark and a little bit more
optimistic about the possibilities you
know one of the things that we did but
he added us we love all of our
commercial paper and draw a lot of
prints and billion dollars that's the 58
banks that we negotiated with and I had
to meet with these 58 banks every 30
days and basically kind of report an
update and at the end of the day we had
to get all 58 banks to sign on a renewal
within 24 months because it was an
expiring line of credit or else it was
you know the whole line wouldn't renew
so we would be bankrupt immediately and
I had some serious doubts about whether
or not we would be successful with that
I think that was probably the loneliest
part of the job is is that you don't get
to have those conversations with many
people you get to have the conversation
about how difficult things are and
trying to put a realistic perspective
but you have to balance it with the fact
that we can we can get there and we can
do it and keep people engaged and
motivated so I'd say that was one of the
things that probably was most difficult
was just lots of nights kind of lying in
bed and thinking about you know the
security of all these people that was at
stake if we weren't successful with some
of the things
and no way but you know I think it's the
first time in my life that I wasn't in a
job with lots of peers people that I
could kind of talk to and hang out with
and share concerns or be a critic and so
that was a learning experience for me I
have to say and one that took its toll
I'd say during the first couple of years
because it did require kind of an
internal mechanism for dealing with the
stress of some of the situations and it
was a tough time it was one over here
and their sources of honesty and
critique and I'm wondering where did you
find those sources were they internally
externally and how to do solicit that
kind of well the ones that are most
helpful to me are usually employees and
customers because they really see what's
happening so you know there's nothing
more sobering than going to visit a
really unhappy customer about you know
what their experience has been and what
the problems have been and I did a lot
of it I do lessen it now because we have
less hopefully unhappy customers but but
getting that firsthand feedback and
dealing with frustrations and the issues
firsthand I think with the marketplace
is really important inside the company
it's actually easier than you would
think
there's constituencies that are very
outspoken we have you know 8,000
technicians who pour on the streets
every day solving technical problems and
they're not aspiring to be CEO they're
like let me tell you what's wrong with
this company
and so a lot less political overhanging
use for any constituencies if you create
an environment where they can speak
freely and we do tons of business get
like agent partners and people that see
xerox from arm's length and it gives
them a freedom to provide input and
feedback that's hugely important so
there are tons of sources I think the
real key is is that you actually have to
thank people and make them feel valued
for giving you the feedback versus shoot
them and that's the first instinct you
have is defense and you have to just
kind of learn to absorb it and take it
away and know that it's a gift and and
process it and deal with it but they're
there to be had you just have to create
the environment yes 28 years how do you
go through these steps and he's sticking
with the same company it's something you
recommend so it was probably one of the
most important reasons why I could do
what I did at Xerox this is you know it
was a lot more emotion than it was logic
probably in terms of a lot of the effort
that we put in at the time it was very
very it was not well accepted in the
market if you read them the headlines on
may of 2000 and would have actually been
very very negative because the
conventional thinking was is that when a
big company runs into trouble gets into
a crisis what you need is literally an
outside turnaround expert who can be
somewhat ruthless and quick and solve
the problems and get it back on its feet
and then you can turn it over to a more
sustainable team or something but so it
was not well-received it was not the day
that I was announced to see
the stock dropped 15% character that's
right so so no but I when I think back
on it you know it was so hugely
important in terms of developing the
loyalty and the relationships and
building the team and I had such a head
start because of what I knew about the
place what I I was one of them and I
really felt that you know the culture
was usually important that there was a
head to be a pride in a respect and a
relationship about how we did this so
that people hold their heads high and
and that's not to say by the way I'd say
a third of my team is hired from the
outside so this is not a requirement but
I think for this particular set of
circumstances I viewed it as a
tremendous asset and I think that you
know there's always going to be a mix
and companies of people who speak for
long periods of time and and those that
you know you bring in for external
perspective and groom at different
points in their careers so that's that's
a good thing but I have this goal and I
know that it used to be and it may be
well it's in vogue to say you know you
kind of have to build this portfolio of
experiences to you know really develop
your career I want to hire every Xerox
person with the goal of making it a
place they want to stay for a long time
I actually want them to come with that
same motivation that they can see a way
that this could be a place they'd love
to have their whole careers it may not
work out but I think both company and
individual are served a lot better if
that's the motivation for joining a
company
and hiring an employee so I'm sort of
trying to instill that into the fabric
of the company that you know we really
would love to have people stay and be
with us and have careers that are really
fulfilling for long periods of time well
I think the thing that probably I am a
worrier
by nature and so I will always find
something to be concerned about but you
know if someone asked me what motivated
me more success or failure I would
probably say failure and you know I
think that's one where I run really hard
to avoid failure more that I run towards
success I think and therefore I think it
almost makes me nervous that we're at a
place where people kind of think it's
business as normal you know business as
usual so it's trying to not put our feet
up and and fall into some of the
characteristics that I think got us into
trouble in the first place and having a
level of intensity it's a different goal
okay we're about growth and greatness
now and not just about survival but you
need I think that same level of
intensity and passion going forward and
that's that's a big challenge to try to
sustain that you know I tend to think
that right now crisis was a more
powerful motivator and then perhaps you
know the goal to being a great company
again and
that's my job I've got to make sure that
that's in place but it is something that
certainly worries me that that this next
stage of the journey is one that I
really got a whole different set of
things to accomplish than the last piece
of it and equally important so what
advice do you give to other companies
there in similar situation instead there
needs to be some culture
to change but yet it is so important for
yeah so you know I generally say you've
got to find the good restraints the
competencies and the strengths and the
value system and cultures and and really
use it as your Northstar so that people
feel this sense of we're not just a big
company we actually stand for something
and a lot of that's embedded in the
culture so identifying that and calling
it out during times of change I think is
just so important and for Xerox it was
all about you know our community
involvement and I mean we did more
probably community volunteering in the
last four years than we did in the
previous ten because we really focused
on the fact that that is part of what
we're about as company and that's why
this company has to be great again and
we didn't we have a foundation and you
know we continued to use our foundation
for that kind of thing so identifying
that core set of things that you can use
for grounding while you go ruthlessly
after the things that really have to be
changed I think gives people a path that
they want to come they want to follow
and I believe kind of the definition of
leadership is followership and that
that's what you have to create something
that people feel proud about and that
they want to participate in and want to
be a part of and that's I think how you
have to break down culture so that you
can deliver the change but give people a
sense of pride and ownership in history
and reputation that I think is a big
part of what keeps people
so well thank you all for participating
on your day off
you